hello and welcome to lobby game so its
weekly hangout oh by govern got over
back right it's all good hey don't worry
about it hello and welcome to the lobby
case wats weekly hang out every Tuesday
2 p.m. pacific right here on gamespot
com I'm your host Andy Dwyer fresh back
from Germany full of pork knuckle vice
beer and God knows what else and i'm
joined by Alex new house hey Danny
journey with us for another week right
yeah that's true congratulations thank
you in turn know the summer did a great
job thank you could [ __ ] it up right now
though we see Eric take what up how you
doing doing our sweet shirt oh thanks
you always wear a nice shirt when you're
gonna be on the lobby I have to now you
know it's trying to step up the game hey
office here we gotta get a little bit
yeah slightly more professional maybe
look at this cash I said my stepped on
my game to match you a little bit great
yeah there's the only piece of clothing
I have that's washed after spending a
week in Europe so that's why I'm wearing
that one glad you're clean and you two
are here which means we're talking about
one particular game come on that game
yeah last time you guys hi John we had a
great chat about destiny and now we're
gonna have another one the taken king is
out in just a couple of weeks September
right around the corner and not only is
it bringing obviously a bunch more
content for the low low price of forty
dollars but on the day of release
there's also going to be a patch coming
out for all destiny players it's gonna
change up a bunch of stuff let's talk
about that first so the first thing we
know is that dinkle bought out and nolan
north sin and what do you guys think
about that i think it's i think it's
great like I you know dinklage peter
dinklage is a good actor hmm wasn't
great and destiny and for them to get
nolan earth north someone who's you know
tried and true and video games like that
just seems like a good move for them
they're going back and completely
scrapping it like scrapping dinklage
from the entire game going back and
replacing every single line that the
ghost says hip with nolan north it's a
little aggressive rewriting his yeah
it's a little it's a little aggressive
kind of feel bad for Dinklage but at the
same time it makes sense and i feel like
nolan north will do a better job okay
another big change Elijah's being
completely scrapped in terms of what
something scrapped but in terms of XP
progression past level 20 just like pre
level 20 your XP will be gotten directly
from quests and sort of in line with
most other MMO e-type character level
online games hey what do you think about
that yeah I think it's good I think
you know looking back at you know
original destiny and think you're just
how light level work it was kind of a
little bit confusing at first it's like
oh I kind of hit max level but it's not
really max level because gear takes me
to this higher level so now you're like
you said it's going back to a
traditional kind of style where it's all
experience based and all the armor and
weapons you get will just make you a
stronger guardian so it's like as you
progress through the game it's like okay
I got right to your armor that has 100
or 300 more armor than my last armor
more it's easier to understand and I
think the interesting thing to come out
of that for me is is this kind of going
to start this whole thing with Charles
of Osiris which is their new kind of PvP
mode yeah with what wow did which is
like now we can p we can balance for PvP
and for PvE because we can give special
stats to PvP and like here's different
gear that's right specifically for PvP
that's what I'm kind of interested about
they haven't talked about it but I
wouldn't be surprised if there's
something like there's many more that
the changes I know like you will have to
go back to the tower as much with
bounties and quests and whatnot is there
anything else they're doing that's kind
of jumped out here or are they the two
main ones with that update specifically
I mean I think like the hut overhaul is
incredibly important as well because
it's just like they're making it so that
you can you can track the progress in
your quests in your bounties on the HUD
itself which is huge like you don't have
to you know pop up the menu during
earring play sessions and stuff not
having to go back to the tower is also
really essential but really the light
level the light level overhaul is
probably the biggest change that they're
making to this you two are big fans of
Destiny I'm gonna throw her this little
devils advocate thing out there it's
great like it's like I always you know
my was a big sort of like touchstone for
me with this sort of stuff whenever a
big expansion pack comes out they always
launch a sort of a big patch around that
time as well where they kind of update a
bunch of stuff for everybody else isn't
the fact that they're going back and
like rewriting the main story character
in this game and isn't the fact that
they're like getting rid of this pretty
like fundamental aspect of their
progression doesn't that sort of mostly
show you that the game they made last
year was just wasn't that good like
they're changing fundamental parts of
the game okay so you're mostly right I
mean a lot of people on the internet
have been saying oh we just went through
destiny beta like to beta and now then
like now we're getting to the point
where it's like real destiny it was a
real expensive beta
I sure the thing is just like a lot of
games now just again we'll talk trends
it's like it's an evolving system right
like yeah maybe the destiny that we got
originally wasn't as good as it's gonna
be now because like a lot of games
iterate on quality of life stuff and
that's really what destiny did right
they found a lot of the quality of life
stuff and they kind of up the game on
that and made it better and what do you
have a quality of life so like um for
example you know not only did the light
level kind of get easier to understand
but you know they figured out okay like
factions you used to have to wear a
special piece of armor turn it in to get
your rep now it's no you don't have to
wear that you just pledged yourself to a
faction right or um there used to be coo
ssible marks and vanguard mark so used
to be separate things that you could
earn and you would get capped each week
guess what it's all lumped into one now
like so there's a lot of these kind of
like my new changes that isn't that big
of a deal but like for a player like me
that's been playing it's like oh I wish
I had that in the beginning so it's like
anyone that starts now they won't
understand some of the trials and
tribulations that we want you and to get
back to your story thing they are trying
to deal with that a little bit part of
it is with the rewriting of Dinklage and
we bring in nolan north but you you will
be able to like scan more objects in the
world now that will give you more like
lore behind it it's they said it's not
necessarily like the grimoire cards that
still isn't in the game which is
mind-boggling because there's so much
deep rich lure in that sense I guess and
it sounds like they're actually worth
reading so it's kind of strange that
they exact but the best or stuff is in
the grim already yeah crazy so they are
trying to give you those at least
nuggets we're in the password you just
walk by like oh I don't know what's
going on now it's like you might be able
to scan a dead body you might be able to
scan like a structure and you'll get
like little snippets from either Nolan
North himself or I think air is more
like it'll tap back to like the tower
like it'll have this radio interaction
of like oh so what the hell is this kind
of thing like now you can maybe do that
process of tightening up some of that
stuff yeah it's pretty important at
getting onto the taken king and forty
dollars it's their big expansion
obviously we've had a bunch of them
around the price of 20 bucks which is
kind of a price point people still
aren't really sure what they're getting
for at forty dollars is more in line
with the sort of what we expect of most
she packs most MMO packs and stuff like
that Alex first of all as a fan of
destiny even paying for a bunch but
you're also like you've been very
critical as tears and but probably more
so critical of something special box
what do you think about the taken King
in terms of its value prospect so I've
actually been surprised by what they've
been saying about it because you know
last time I was on here i talked about
how predatory the pricing of you know
destiny has but yeah but what they
seemed like all of their rhetoric around
the taken King has sounded and a lot of
ways very humbled like they're
acknowledging the fact that the light
level system was sort of broken and they
put you know brought players down the
wrong the wrong lines it they're
acknowledging the fact that some of
their weapons have been unbalanced and
there they made a game in which everyone
uses the gala torn yeah and as they say
that that isn't a good thing they want
to encourage people to experience the
entire breadth of it and so what they're
doing with the taken King they when they
talk about it they make it they make it
clear like they are going back to the
story and making the story campaign
something that people actually want to
play it's gonna be like twice as long as
we're not in halves of wolves I Bering
yeah what they say yeah we'll see I mean
like say they have been saying that yeah
like they are putting a significant
amount of story content in there which
to be fair you know that isn't saying
much relative the rest of destiny but
they are adding you know far more
cinematics in both dark blue and house
of wolves had one at the intro right as
one of them more between each mission
you know they've got this whole like
take everything they talk about the
endgame after you finish the story they
haven't even discussed the details of
the yep event yet but they keep talking
about it as this huge expansive like
pretty new thing that they're doing
after you get out of the story campaign
so I from what they've been talking
about i'm actually really hopeful that
this will be worth forty dollars like
both of you played the game of bunch you
obviously love it a lot and say how
important is this expansion pack to you
as a fan of destiny to keep you hooked
in because obviously like getting
certain like a piecemeal quests and an
odd crucible map and some of the in the
old expansion packs like there's this
needs to be a sort of a larger amount of
content to keep you engaged this one's
gonna be a big test for me because it's
like I still like destiny I still like
playing a lot but I've dwindled whatever
that is for me that's right compared to
anyone else but for me right so as one
of the hardcore players right this one's
going to
tell me a lot of am I gonna keep playing
or am I going to play a lot less and am
I going to keep convenient lose friends
after this one if this one doesn't
deliver you know but they are adding a
lot of stuff so now it just comes down
to really let's play it let me see if I
feel like it's worth the forty dollars
but I will say this is gonna be whatever
but like it isn't good I think if you
haven't played destiny this is a very
good values never been there I got
hooked on there's a lot like honestly
though like I wish like in some in some
ways I almost wish like I was able to
get all of that stuff now for sixty
dollars and understand why we have to go
a peon I didn't understand why you kill
a Theon the first time cuz I don't read
the grimoire cards cuz now in the game
yeah you know but now you'll know why so
do you expect to play through the story
mission and be left on a massive cliff
hanger likes new house I really hope not
I really hope this is gonna lead
directly into the rest of the game you
know directly into the Kings fall rated
and what they've they've also been
saying that going back and reworking all
the bounties from the previous like the
base game and the previous expansions to
make those tie and more they're really
trying to make it all tie together
obviously talking about it like that
like they are which sounds really
promising me all right gentlemen we've
had you want to talk about destiny a
bunch thank you so much again for coming
on last question and we gave destiny six
out of them yeah right successes and air
teh Alex new house give me your score
for destiny after year one based on your
own experiences Eric at a time we're
doing this base on gamespot right so no
halves right no happier haps not enough
1000 man no heroes either I think it's I
think it's still a seven I think it yeah
that's I always thought it was a seven I
still think it is but I can also see why
people might think it's a 6.4 me seven
all right Alex which got I go back and
forth I you know when I'm 45 so close
when I was deep in like house house of
wolves I was like this is an eight or a
nine like I was loving it but now now
that I'm back you know now that I've
heard what they're doing and stuff i'm
i'm sitting around a 77 all right it's
got a [ __ ] thing I hear word around the
office of you might be doing a review
after year I guess we'll have to wait
and see if that's the case you know
taste shaking his head I know if that
means no
or don't do it would be paya taking king
of you okay yeah we'll see we'll see
soon enough jama thanks so much for
coming on and we'll be back in just a
minute but first of all here's a trailer
for the second olly olly game Olly Olly
to
what a rocker lane haha I got some
German haxan house for esta spit in
flammen seen outside to get it out of
his system did you see while various
that's vodka or rather starting World of
Warcraft came out in 2004 since then
we've had has a bunch of expansion packs
with that video game Bernie coucher
let's see if we can do them at Eric teh
wrath of the lich congrats you two that
ran through their skin I think justin
LOL sec burning christopher nikka say
thirty percent not the lychgate breath
at cataclysm I think was there something
before cata handle then Padma's no no
cataclysm temp honest then drown or yeah
you guys it's it's the Panda and
Cataclysm that's really not i'm pretty
sure it's no no no i'm pretty sure it's
panda than cat it cuz i didn't play
penned area and then I played Cataclysm
I go back and play everyone for like a
bit two weeks now I'm like all right I
got my better and we're gonna do it all
over again and because Brian expansion
pack lesion is coming out next year and
not a damn minute too soon it would seem
with the we had a bunch of either at the
top of John I think there was like 10
million people playing what's a dent in
everything right it does end yeah that's
the problem like they're announcing this
at the worst possible time like they
should have already announced this
because now it sounds like it's more of
AI mean we know it's not we know they're
working on these expansions as soon as
one is finished yes but it makes it
sound like oh oh now that we're down to
five million we needed an expansion mmm
like and it makes it more reactionary
rather than like here's a planned thing
so what have they said it's in Legion
we've got a demon hunter new class got
new artifact weapons yes there's a new
hero class as well and so it's not like
a regular class you're gonna take it's
more like a the one in Wrath that one
that was added back in Wrath yeah I'm
trying to think about myself um the love
of cops me to death knight day go its
product from 100 to 110 and to be a
bunch of our quest I interviewed the
guys ash gamescom and it sounded like
this is almost entirely end game stuff
like they are concentrating
on the end game how did you go back and
play drown or because from what I'm
hearing for my mates you play where the
end game and that was just not log yeah
like the not much rating lots of just
going out and like accumulating
resources how did you feel fine well I
mean that's it it made it even more of
kind of a mini job where you go in you
check on your your garrison every day
like it's it's fun it's fun in that it
keeps you coming back but it's also the
kind of thing that I can't keep doing
like I just can't invest that much daily
time like I did enjoy like let's run
through the lights level back up and
that that's what legions going to offer
as well like that they're going to be
able to start you out at 100 if you want
a new character like oh cool now i get
another character i can bump up straight
to 100 get right into new content but is
there gonna be stuff to do beyond that
how like how long is it kind of take
again to level up to 110 well they have
a brand new area the broken Isles seems
like they're running out of tricks pizza
dough man they just they just spin it
back in time and then you just reuse it
they did that already amber ever if they
did that already [ __ ] I think that
was lychgate when they went out the all
the sort of ancient time bending stuff
you can do so what I think they're gonna
do eventually is just tie this world
into destiny much like that is not what
destiny starved for content and World of
Warcraft is starved for
microtransactions the Destiny the story
the lore they'll come together they're
both Activision Blizzard those worlds
will come together that you have a first
person i can't wait to play yeah that
toys to life activision game that's come
with all their properties and air Tay is
this when was last time you play well I
played Draenor I I did a little bit of
the raid when if the the very first one
I did a couple bosses it was kind of
like old days again it's just one of
those things of how much time you want
to spend to beat it and like get through
it and like do you enjoy it like it's
it's still one of those games where you
can find a guild or clan to join to do
the raid but it's definitely not as fun
when you're not doing with people you
know part of the reason why I loved wow
so much or rating before was because you
get on with your you know 810 friends
whatever it was and then you guys would
kind of like have a little mini social
gathering but still buy the game and so
when I was doing the raid with you know
like a pickup group or something it was
just really kind of hard to get through
it
yes I can't do this and actually I
actually thought even the old like just
lfg stuff was fun because you kind of
had to go meet each other and like make
sauce each other Adwords and when they
added in the like just looking for a
party like immediate like the yeah the
dungeon ey dungeon finder thing it kind
of took that bit of social aspect of it
as well yeah no more no more like direct
message of like I'm a warrior 60 yes
wearing this I'm a 45 pounds but I'm
SPECT for the thing that you don't need
but the thing is though at the end of
the day even if Wow subs are down to
five million it's gonna spike back up to
like seven problems so this is the thing
right I was talking to the to the guys
at Gamescom and one of the things I was
talking about was that peeking and
volleying because obviously they if they
reach up to 10 million in a drop down
what they're seeing is that it's the
highs are getting higher but the loads
are getting lower and they getting
faster so there the more expansion packs
or the later expansion packs are having
more people but a faster fall off or at
least that's what they were sort of
agreeing on and the reason they were
saying that is because they've got an
aging demographic that they reckon is
quicker to drop off and maybe go play
something else and then they're getting
a lot of those people back like people
are almost saying oh that's cool I'll
come back when the next to pack
expansion pack comes Wade feel like what
we're seeing we've never gotten back up
to 15 million like those Peaks are still
in the middle of the last high range oh
yeah like them that high of over 15
million and then down to 10 million and
then own back up to 12 million down to 9
million and it just keeps its slowly
working down like the thing that's going
to change that is when it goes
free-to-play head at this point it has
to be when it's free to play and not is
it going to go free-to-play do you think
it goes free-to-play cuz one of the
things that I think might happen is that
whenever they are ready for that to go
free-to-play is when Blizzard launched
their new MMO I'm not saying that that's
not going to be the case like we still I
could see this being even two years out
three years out but I think it has to
happen eventually and then that's when
they're gonna well I mean are they gonna
do another is there is there room for
another world of warcraft type MMO like
thinking about this expansion and how
much time we've invested like how many
how much these subs have gone down no
one's ever been able to replicate what
World of Warcraft is done and what that
both what that means to us except maybe
in terms of Destin
can they even match that again with a
massively multiplayer online game well
how is why I'm still retaining it
because it's not like there wasn't like
Guild Wars came out and everyone thought
all and you did see that initial like
MMO people are so transient like they
moved from one game to another all the
time we saw people go to guild awards
and go to go where's Tim come back we
saw people go to Old Republic and come
back but like even if their numbers are
only around the you know five six mini
range like that's a lot of people so you
can keep them hook to get them a noose
patching bag surely the one to do it
again yeah it's like this huge nostalgic
feeling it's all the time you invested
in your characters it's it's all of that
it's in your head like I've spent so
much time playing this game here all ten
of my characters or whatever I have like
the few friends that I still play with
Yallah top shape and play guild wars 2
or let's hop ship and play wildstar
because everyone's trying to find the
wow killer I hate using that term
because everyone uses that term but I
always looked at it as wow will never
die until Blizzard decides to kill it
off or make a game that kills it off
right and so those games just don't have
the hook because everyone has this thing
where they compared to wow and when they
get to some point in that new game that
they try it's like oh man but you know
what wow it is better than this and then
they start doing that and then that's
when the drop-off happens and then they
go back to wow yeah and then everyone
like you said they they'll play they
stopped because they get tired of while
or whatever and then it's like oh new
expansion I'm all-in watch blizzcon is
gonna have that effect it grabs everyone
every time it was the craziest thing for
me was like III destiny taken King it
hooked like three or four people in the
office back in that I don't even see
really playing at all and they're all
like oh yeah I'm totally in so like
obviously Activision is doing something
like right with marketing or some people
always have that thing where they want
to go back to the character they've made
but that doesn't happen a lot of other
MMOs like people you--you'll max at a
character in the Old Republic or and get
any of those games and it it doesn't
have that same hook but like what is it
just is there something about the world
that they've made is it something about
that is that the time is that the fact
that we playing playing this game for
over a decade like what do you think it
is about war the warcraft specific that
gets people coming back for me that's
what it is it's just that i've played it
for so long that it's that I both have
memories of having played with my
friends that I mean the first in
know that I really got into was final
fantasy 11 hmm and and that never drew
me like that for me and playing with my
friends it was so so much of a slog in
an world warcraft gurak came along it's
like this is what I wanted like everyone
sayings for babies but it's fun it's so
accessible and like every all my other
friends are playing it and like I still
have those good memories and I still
want to get them back when there's a new
expansion that comes out even if it
doesn't quite capture it even if it only
captures it for a week or a month you
see the last month thanks yeah cuz
everyone everyone's like oh yeah let's
get back into it and then like you have
your five friends or something that you
kind of play with then you're like
alright sweet and then y'all level up
and I you do a couple dungeons and then
you see one guy stop then you see the
next guy stop then you see the next guy
stuff and then lo and behold I'm the one
dude sitting in like by myself like oh
yeah and Barnes Chuck I realized why I
don't normally agree to this and I feel
like I got suckered by my friends but
it's like that mini camaraderie and the
net in fact of life oh yeah like when
the expansion comes out you get to
experience something slightly new in wow
that you didn't get to before and that's
like but you also said this how'd you
feeling yeah like oh yeah you get you
know so you get a little bit of both
I've this thing where I go back and I
almost go back and not to even play the
new stuff but it's like when I go back
and visit my hometown and I like I just
walk into the grounds of my old school
like just to see what they've changed
you know like oh I remember look around
that's where I you know that's where I
did that that's where I scored that goal
and that's right bought those drugs off
that guy and then oh look they painted
it really only by much different look is
that's different like oh look there's
some kid buying drugs over there that
little massage you feeling I last
question for you guys I just enabled
will you go back and play I mean golly I
like I no matter what i love the limited
editions like is embarrassing is I know
my [ __ ] them all I have all of them like
my shelf every I gotta say god they look
so good on the Shelf like they just look
like next to my books I don't mention
him off showing them up like a girl
comes over looks in my bookshelves like
I look at all the books and some wild
things you don't even know the world
worked up those are classy video if i
watch it what's your / played haha no
one's ever said Eric hey will you go
back and play Legion um I won't unless
it's for work I'm a liar that's a god
you're here can empathize with I I did
make a strong stand at one point I
didn't play miss affair
I played a little bit of Cataclysm
because my friends really pushed out
that was great that was the ultimate
going back and see how messed up your
school is because it was just like oh
I'm gonna go to place I didn't give a
[ __ ] about the first time just as oh
look a Thousand Needles it's a flooded
and [ __ ] was great I hope that we'll see
all right and let us know what you think
about Legion and whether or not you're
gonna go back and play when it comes out
sometime next year we're probably
offended at blizzcon all right we'll be
back in just a second first of all we've
got a new trailer for that video game
about the wrasslin I talked Daniel Bryan
III all right song yes you only ever
wrestle again no no I don't know yeah
find anything I hope he will I hope you
see them back in the ring but if we
don't you can play them in WWE 2k16
let's check out a brand new entrance for
that video game
this guy will settle for nothing short
of a victory here tonight thank you for
spending part of your evening with us we
think you're really going to enjoy this
upcoming match
it's been almost 15 years since we first
saw the mafia game break out onto the pc
is well pipe laid it on the city of lost
heaven and matthew to was kind of a good
game was ok wasn't wasn't too fantastic
and but fans we're very happy to see the
Mafia 3 has been announced peter brown
although some of those fans took a
little bit of exception to the i guess
the the focus the character perhaps the
time in the setting first of all peter
matthew three you saw some of it what
did you think of what you saw uh i mean
there are two sides to mafia three that
are worth talking about right i mean
there is the gameplay aspect where you
know it is a game that's very much got
the whole you know a lot of shooting a
lot of driving you know kind of does a
lot of the same stuff that GTA does and
some that mafia has done in the past but
the series is taking a very interesting
term in turn in terms of the the setting
and the themes so it's said in 1960s or
1968 i believe and in New Orleans which
is a very iconic city for many reasons
but I think what most people are
interested in for I mean I'd like to
think for better but also unfortunately
for worse is the race of the main
character you play Lincoln clay who is a
you grew up an orphan and he sort of
spent his whole life searching for a
family right you know he joined the
church join gangs ultimately ended up in
the Army going to the Vietnam War and
now he's on the streets of New Orleans
trying to find life in the the Mafia
scene which is all really interesting
but you know he is also a black man and
at that period in North America
especially in the south racism you know
segregation where were big deals and and
they were they presented a whole lot of
difficulties for a man like Lincoln clay
and so this subject matter is unusual
for a video game and based on the short
amount of you know footage that I saw of
the game yeah I I don't know if mafia
three is gonna do this subject matter
justice hmm but it could I mean we have
to wait and see it seems like the sort
of era and the sort of story that you
would really need to dive into headfirst
to do it justice yeah what about it what
you've seen so far sort of let you think
that perhaps they're they're they're
using a norm as window dressing or
then really it being like the focus will
what's giving you that impression right
now a scary prospect for any developer
you gotta say as well dude it's
difficult for me to even talk about it
yeah you know like I I certainly don't
represent anyone except people like
myself well my own perspective and that
is not who the main character is but you
know to me I can't say that I think it's
just window dressing right now I don't
know that but the issues of race come up
at many points during the demo that I
saw which you know included you know
racial slurs being you know thrown at
Lincoln at other characters and it was
done in such a way where the people
doing it were pretty nonchalant about it
which I can only imagine was what it was
like back then it doesn't I don't think
that they're using that just to sort of
raise alarms and stir up controversy I
think there's a really interesting
discussion to have here and you know
it's for a video game to be something
that is one a medium for storytelling
but also a medium for you know if we sit
in case a mafia-like action and gameplay
and stuff like that it's that's where I
see perhaps the biggest opportunity for
this to fall apart you know frankly I
the gameplay to me compared to the story
set in the setting is I almost don't
care like I think there's a really
interesting story to be told here for
sure like African Americans have been
not very represented in video games
history right and I remember probably
growing up for me in Ireland that may be
that the first one I really recognized
with CJ in San Andreas and then you've
got a situation in which your African
American character is one that's
involved in criminal activities in gang
culture in a fictional version of
California why not and we've seen it in
Assassin's Creed we've seen more
african-american over the course of the
past couple years you've just seen
greater diversity or I've seen a lean
towards greater diversity in video games
in relation to a gender and race as well
and I want to talk to you about one
aspect of us which is the kind of I kind
of hate talking about it because we're
basically like recognizing what should
perhaps be ignored but like one of the
things that notice there on the video we
put up at Gamescom and on your story as
well as this sword
of this like vitriol it is backlash to
it being used almost as if the idea of
having an african-american by its
definition as a main character was some
sort of plea to appeal to like the left
audience or it's some sort of like a
bending of the knee to some sort of
liberal and ideas what do you think
about that it does it say more to do
with sort of most Caucasians that we
immediately jump to that that like you
can't tell a story about the Mafia
because it's about the Italian mob with
a black person it's I mean I don't think
it's one thing mmm from my perspective I
think it's partially fear on behalf of
the audience because they might not want
to be confronted with these issues I saw
several people saying great another game
where I'm going to be told that i'm a
racist right yeah yeah and and that's
not why this is important it's not to
tell white people that they shouldn't be
proud of who they are or whatever but
what this is is an opportunity for a of
society that is very much important as
any other group to have a chance to have
their story told and examined and you
know what their perspective understood
so to see people sort of backlash at
this I think yes comes from a place of
fear and you know it's it's also a
maturity people are veiling their
argument and you know these are mafia
games like why should it have why isn't
it why isn't in italian / yet
protagonist why isn't Joe Pesci every
rep video game's protagonist right it's
look I think there's there's no place
for for hate in any part of society it
just doesn't do anyone any good and if
you don't identify with the character
then that's maybe not a game that you
need to concern yourself with yeah but
there are plenty of people who are
interested in seeing these different
stories be told and participating in
these discussions so I implore people to
just have an open mind and really just
think about what opportunities this game
presents that other games just fail to
mmm and I guess last question about this
do you think were we do you think we
will start to see I guess where we tend
to see a lot of the time now is is that
there is more diversity in games not
just in the main protagonist but in
terms
stories were seeing in terms of the
different experiences we're seeing and
you know everyone's gone to the rapture
came out this week I remember when gone
home came out a couple years ago the
amount of vitriol that was getting
poured at that game at the time saying
this isn't a game we're seeing a bit of
that and with the latest game but it's
not to the same level so do you think
that we are slowly but surely creeping
towards a medium in which these types of
things can be talked about and these
types of games can be announced and its
celebrated and less so than that we're
seeing less of this sort of weird you
know overly sensitive backlash to it do
you think we're getting there or does it
feel like it's the same as it was five
ten years ago I think we're in the midst
of the struggle that will turn the tide
I don't think we've gotten to the point
where we're going to be able to tell
these stories without there being some
sort of controversy behind the
announcement people will continue to be
upset about it until it becomes
something that isn't an exception to the
rule but it's part of the general you
know flow of the industry and yeah we're
probably going to see some people you
know try to make gains because they want
more diversity and that's fine like
that's a worthy cause and I think to shy
away from something like that is I don't
see the value in shying away from trying
to welcome more people in the gaming so
you know I don't think I don't think
it's ever going to be fair
representation for all groups in society
at any point I think you know the
majority will still unfortunately the
the majority that want to just play like
a white male you know will continue to
get what they want but you know I really
hope games like mafia can come out and
handle these discussions properly and
show people that these are things worth
having and worth discussing but I don't
think we're at that point yet where a
game like this can come out and not be
judged by the color of the main
character skin that that is obviously
still an issue and who knows what it's
going to take him so much less time for
games an exciting time as well clearly
we're seeing some some games coming out
there and pushing at the boat and it
it's not not a dime sign too soon as
well a Peter and thank you so much for
coming on talking about not leavin
in here he's sticking around Robert go
to marry final fantasy final fantasy
just as well he's here cuz i got a new
laptop and they've just locked in the
air so i don't the running order is
you'll marry what's the next trailer
it's for call of duty white male
protagonist let's roll it call of duty
Final Fantasy 15 those fancy phones been
looking forward to this bad boy for a
long time looks like they won't have to
wait that much longer alexa ray korea
Peter Brown and his super loud laptop
here on what's going on there what's
going on blazing up there yeah yep that
word is really pushing this core i7
processor is fry an egg on that bad boy
yeah Final Fantasy 15 excited yeah
excited yeah tell me about what happened
at Gamescom you went to interview a
gentleman who might have been making
that game and he might have slipped a
little bit of details to you yeah Hajime
Tabata is the director of finance to
type 0 and now Final Fantasy 15 he took
over the verses 13 project back in 2012
and then made it 15 and yeah we spoke a
lot about where the game is how long
we're gonna have to wait to play it and
this came after a presentation that him
and his team gave at Gamescom which was
very lackluster in terms of new
information they brought all this great
stuff and they what they showed a short
story trailer they revealed an enemy and
showed a main character whose name is
the black haired girl her name right
they call her this drape like black hair
girl I am as in her hair is straight
hair straight ok um I have to say I've
been waiting for this game for 10 years
yeah uh that presentation inspired no
confidence in me that that game is
coming out yeah next year at all they
have a character that they refer to
internally by her hair color so she's
have a name they still don't know I
talked to ciabatta as well back in
January he said you know airships were
working on the technology we don't know
if we can do it they said the same thing
at Gamescom they said well we can get
him the high that the height that a bird
would fly but we don't really know and
they showed what enemy which looks like
it's in an area very similar to what
we've seen in episode does this the
enemy how does the animators malboro a
final fantasy staple and um they didn't
the trailer was two and a half minutes
of a guy holding his kid what's your
watch anything but that kid looks so
real and it's a grief looked so good
great and also that guy it's [ __ ]
raining man like don't hold your kid out
get your kid damp I
no I'm like I don't know the trailer was
just a place that's a straight girl
because I think they had to redo that
texture i I don't know the fact that
there's a main character without a name
and there's we've seen very little new
areas and that they don't know whether
or not they can use the technology that
they have available to them to make
something work uh 10 years into the dev
psychol I don't I don't know I'm
skeptical that would contradict what
that we heard spent on horses Matt Peter
and so you asked him when abouts will
see it he said I can definitely tell you
it's not this year and then he rambled
on a bit and he said I can certainly
tell you you don't have to wait until
2017 hmm so now obviously you know that
says 2016 we put up the story saying
that square didn't jump down our throats
or anything PR double check before we
printed it so you know we're good you
know one of the things that people are
sort of a trying to wrap their head
around is the different percentages that
to body gives out right at TGS last
september's said the game was fifty
fifty-five percent on at Gamescom during
his presentation he said 65 oh so that
makes it sound like you know ten percent
a year early access right but 2016 so I
asked him you know what have you done
over the last year and he was like all
right before we talk about what's been
happening over the last year let me just
clear up the thing about the numbers I
said normally when we describe it we
think like in terms of numbers we think
about it internally as how long have we
got until the mastering of the game okay
right so if you think about that that's
sixty-five percent until the game is
actually like printed right so 2012 to
now that would be what that's like three
years maybe a handful of months yeah so
if you think about you give it another
year like let's say a year and a half
right just to be fair I gave it to
December that could happen without those
percentages but when he's talking about
the actual content of the game itself he
told me that it's over seventy percent
know what so it's like sixty-five
percent ready to print but what's in the
game is seventy percent done try so in
terms of patterns of the assets little
programming the things that the things
that we're missing here are first of all
you need to localize the game this is
and I'm sort of spoiling a news story
we're going to put up this is the first
no
final fantasy game that they're planning
to release simultaneously worldwide oh
wow some way yes dude Ricky news yes
Ashley yeah so now they still have to do
all the localization in that regard and
they still have to like master all the
discs right and ship those out all over
the world you ready to go QA perhaps as
part of that he was part of that right
so yeah the content stuff is worrisome
when they're talking about airships
maybe being a thing maybe not but he did
state that it could come as DLC and and
just this morning they were talking
about perhaps working with the Avalanche
Studios and to sort of get their their
tech from Just Cause to give the game
greater verticality now implementing
tech from one engine to another is not
really something you can do overnight I
I think he was probably saying something
along the lines of and we've had these
thoughts we're having those discussions
but look I don't expect they're going to
put air ships in before this game of
ships I asked to bottle why are you the
right man for the job after so many
years people have so many concerns why
should they trust you and he said that
my strongest skill is setting a timeline
and optimizing a team getting things
done with certain goals in mind and then
proceeding forward so he sounds like he
is a very like you know strict militant
approach to how he's managing this
project project when you compare that to
Nomura who blessed his heart is a
recluse is known for not communicating
well with his teams and works on like
six major projects at a time Tabata is
yeah like Tabata is in a great position
to actually buckle down say all right
deep breath hmm here's when we want to
ship the game here are the milestones we
need to hit for every aspect of the game
let's just rally together and do it well
sound good everybody it sounds great
also let's get Rico Rodriguez in this
game just really not um here's my
question no no no if you talk to him
about this but something else that sort
of makes me really skeptical about this
is they released dusk a the first 13
months later they released dust k 2
point 0 and dusk a two-point o's combat
was so different they fixed the
targeting they fixed a lot of other
stuff they fixed speed and then they
added a bunch of a tax so the fact that
they went back and then changed all of
the combat based on player feedback in
this to our demo
like based on if the game is done at all
would they go back and change all of the
combat in the game like is that simple
to do is that hard like why did they do
that I mean so combat is obviously
taking place like in a broad range of
environments against many different
enemies but and its core it really is a
singular system that has variables that
can be tweaked so even if they've got
combat set for the entire game like
let's just pretend all the environments
are made maybe I don't have textures all
the combat scenarios are there one tweak
to the system will come into effect
across the entire game so if they're
using episode dust gay as sort of a
focus test you know sample right to kind
of get people's opinions they can tweak
something and although we only see it
reflected in that small demo that is a
thing that will be you know impacted
across the entire game it's kind of
crazy to think about them doing that
like I was actually rather impressed by
how quickly they managed to change the
combat because okay obviously they're
not sort of like it's a bubble of that
area you know but you don't have to then
QA every single instance of what you've
changed across the entire game again
think about it this way you know there
are bridge simulators where you
construct a bridge and send a car or
truck already as playing them on the
bathroom this morning right so it's just
as simple as changing the girders on
your bridge and getting a different
result right that's it's just iteration
so much of the content creation in this
game the time is spent in things like
the visual style like how do we set up
this world but when it comes down to the
things that are programmed the things
based on hard numbers such as the flow
and speed of combat that's the thing
that really is just iterating certain
variables you have to balance it there
in anything sure look like you know one
of those girders that was like or let's
just say like a piece of land that was
in this game that wasn't really set
perfectly right but this version this
build worked yeah like maybe when you
change one of those variables it
suddenly it all falls apart again like
its kind of worried it like if they've
got all the content on it then they're
like tweaking all these systems I'm not
saying it's like a watertight system
right like and every game is different
in this regard but if you really think
about it they're not having to change
every single combat scenario one by one
by one by one by one yeah they got a QA
tester stuff and you can break things
very easily but at the same time if they
do it incremental steps there's a good
chance that they can actually iterate in
a in a logical sound way that won't
break the game interesting it's been a
fascinating
vote for developments looking forward to
seeing it at 2016 one question about
that you asked them a one-stage when the
original what they were originally
targeting was no during the interview I
just make that up I think he made her
doesn't make that up my making up things
again didn't it want they said when they
announced 13 and verses 13 and og toe
which became type 0 that they wanted
them all to come out i think it was like
around the same time yeah that sounds
about right i think if we look at this
now like at 2012 things started over all
other previous statements made didn't
hold water anymore and based on what
Tabata told me which is in line with his
description of his own strengths is when
he took over the project then the
timeline was set that's what I was
answering within that time line there
exactly where they hoped to be to hit
that release date which he told me was
before 2017 cool so I can only assume
that he's not lying to me because I'm a
trustworthy guy and maybe that I guess
I'll find out soon enough x-ray korea
peter brian thank you very much coming
on at 2016 for Final Fantasy 15 a lot of
snow if you think it's gonna come out
there in the comments below and then
check back in and say 18 months and see
if you were right or if you were wrong
you will probably wrong that's the lobby
for this week a but first of all we've
got the best giveaway ever check out
this division snow globe listen to globe
it's a snow globe from the division oh
boy oh my god nuclear fallout you hold
that all right not just giving away a
[ __ ] snow globe how do I we've also
got this sick pair of headphones I'm
gonna take this level sure LexA gets
then you get the other sick parent phone
Oh to stick pairs of head you're not
gonna win both of them they're part of
two different packs from giving away
right here on gamespot dog it's like I'm
really on the set of the lobby it's a
mini look he's perfect i hope to use
headband that's what you do you put one
on one air and now you put the other on
the other year do you get the snuggle
with both of them are just no just one
of them oh how does a bunch of other
stuff of God nov 15 show just cause 3
t-shirts or snow globe you get with both
take it back remove my call of duty
black ops 3 sunny geez put them on your
eyes looked like real rad call a duty
comic book loads of [ __ ] look at
yeah zoom in get him gamespot call
before / mega Monday giveaways mega
Monday giveaways the capital letters are
optional that's it cheaper crash zooming
keep Christ never not be crashing and
there you go that's perfect go F fill in
the forms if you want to follow on
Instagram something i don't know the
page look crazy i don't know if forms
work nowadays I HTML days and last time
I saw that you can win one of these
things headphones snow globes t-shirts
surprises or Peter friend giving away
our new reviews editor in a shocking
turn we want Kevin we want Kevin back
Kevin if you're watching I'm [ __ ]
congratulations by the way thank you on
your new position yeah watch it's a big
shoes to fill yeah it's good thing
didn't just send you to Germany in your
first week yeah oh and that's the joke
for this week thank you very much to
everyone in the back Mary kiss Josh show
Eric tay don Mork anyone else back there
that's it ty route where you add i
bought tied up bottle of whiskey he's
probably off drinking out right now this
son of a [ __ ] and make sure you
subscribe to us on the youtubes we'll be
back live next tuesday t p.m. pacific
right here on gamespot com play some
video games bunch of cool [ __ ] came out
and we'll see you then
you